welcome back the fbi raid
is now a political charade
and kamala flip-flops on supporting cops
former president trump says he'll do
whatever he can to help the country
after the fbi raided his home last week
to recap agents seized classified
records some marked as top secret others
were marked as melania's underwear and
forwarded to bill clinton
but trump claims the records have been
declassified and in an interview with
fox news digital or a physician
he says the country the country's not
gonna stand for another scam quote
people are so angry at what is taking
place whatever we could do to help
because the temperature has to be
brought down in the country if it isn't
terrible things are gonna happen
now following the raid last monday the
fbi sent a bulletin to law enforcement
agencies warning of increased threats
something maybe they should have sent
june of 2020 riots and stuff but anyway
vp president harris aka biden's number
two
[Laughter]
she's second in command
she is second in command criticizing
trump and his supporters for fueling the
backlash against law enforcement
i will say as a former prosecutor but as
a citizen of our nation any attacks on
law enforcement
are completely
unacceptable and any so-called leader
who engages in rhetoric
that in any way suggests that that law
enforcement should be exposed to it's
that kind of danger is irresponsible
entry results in dangerous activities
i just keep waiting for her to tell me
where the oxygen mask is
a sexist would say
[Applause]
that seems vague though what she said
it's almost as if no one no so-called
leader actually called for the fbi to be
attacked
for their safety maybe the supreme court
should join the fbi
so now she cares about the safety of law
enforcement remember this is the same
person who helped raise money to bail
out minnesota rioters sorry mostly
peaceful protesters
they were back on the streets before
residents could shout my business is on
fire and since when does she care about
rhetoric remember she's called everyone
who stands in her way a racist including
her boss during a debate you can't get
more incendiary than that this lady is
about as real as pelosi's expression of
surprise
but
you can't be surprised all the time
but hey i can't get angry at kamala not
when we put her nonsense to bongos
it is critical that we work together
to understand where we are
to recognize and have the courage to
speak truth about what is obsolete
and then to partner to ensure that we
are speaking the same language
with the same motivation
inspired
by the opportunity of it all
[Music]
it's amazing it works every time
brooke as a lawyer a successful lawyer
what do you think of this debate
[Laughter]
i'm so happy that you pointed out the
hypocrisy of kamala harris i mean how
dare she go and pretend that she is some
sort of protectorate of law enforcement
while she's raising money you know for
bail funds but um i'm really impressed
with the way that the trump team is
handling this they're really taking the
high road
they're asking for the volume to be kept
low and anyone with an ounce of
objectivity you don't have to have a law
degree to know that this was total
overkill i mean the way
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the way that you enforce the public
records act is through a subpoena right
you you reserve 15 unannounced uh fbi
officials raiding your house for people
who are hiding dead bodies in their
closet okay not for a former president
and there is absolutely no evidence that
he has not cooperated with the formal
subpoena the former he handed over 15
boxes he had the whole room padlocked
and there's even a letter from the
national archives claiming that he was
cooperating in full so
that's what i have to say
joe
also a lawyer
what is with the lawyer
it's just is this easy to be a lawyer
now yeah you just you borrow 100 000 you
go to law school you you pay it back in
the first year and then you quit that
job because it sucks
um have you been watching this closely
what are your thoughts
on the um on kamala or on trump
whichever one it's not uh let's not i
you know that guy uh trump guy he might
have a whole bunch of stuff very
incriminating in his house
why would he give it to these clowns
yeah you know why i wouldn't give him
anything yeah i mean the way they've
treated him it's it's like why would you
give them anything and then i'm reading
about it and it's just like
papers and uh documents and he's
supposedly in trouble for
declassified documents that he's allowed
to declassify right classified that they
classify and they're highly classified
classified but he's the guy that the the
unilaterally declassified he's the
decider yeah and and so uh it seems like
they're trying a little too hard to find
something so maybe they're i mean this
is obvious they're trying to find
something that ties them to this uh
january 16th i don't know if you heard
about that yeah yeah yeah
it's safe to say that if i'm ever in
court you're not going to be my lawyer
you're right
amazing bass player for the vandals
though yes that's right all right all
right so that's you i mean you can't
have them all no you can't your talent
stack is impressive cat do you have any
fresh intake for intake any any uh uh uh
i'll take it from here thank you
they uh well kamala has not always been
supportive of cops but she's been
unwavering in her support of cop as in
one cop as in
herself uh so we shouldn't be surprised
that she she takes whatever positions
the most convenient and she gets super
passionate about it in this weird way as
if we don't weren't there for all the
other stuff even the brittany griner
thing where she's like this is just you
know a wrongful detention
and it's so wrong they're detaining her
for weed i'm like you sent thousands of
people to jail for marijuana yourself
and she i don't know she just she's
shameless she is she is
she is shameless speaking of
shamelessness
jimmy oh
uh care to comment on i mean you've been
talking about this for hours when you're
on the radio yeah nobody listens stop it
but stop it
that was unnecessary no i know um
i apologize i love that kamala speaks as
if anybody cares what she has to say you
know like kamala is so dumb she studied
for a coveted test you
know but stick with me you're gonna
stick with me
stick with me but hold on this is the
problem there's a real problem in our
country this is a real problem yes okay
it's very hard to trust the fbi period
because we know their agents falsified
documents in the past to get trump but
now we're hearing rumors of nuclear
weapons they won't give us the affidavit
because the affidavit would tell us
specifics so they leaked nuclear for two
reasons one nuclear sounds ominous it
buys them time two liz cheney's dad
probably told her mar-a-lago had weapons
of mass destruction
and that's where we are nice
yeah
all right we should move we got other
stuff to talk about fun stuff
shut up jimmy hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else